ya hemos pasado algunos vídeos
construyendo las bases de lo que
representa el rotacional en tres
dimensiones y ahora vamos a ver cómo
calcularlo así que vamos a partir de un
campo vectorial b y para que sea
justamente un campo vectorial necesita
tener digamos tres entradas para que
esto esté en tres dimensiones ahora bien
un campo vectorial como ya sabemos debe
tener también tres salidas verdad es
decir podríamos pensar en un vector con
tres coordenadas que típicamente
llamamos pq y r y cada uno de estos
depende tanto de x como de g como de z
verdad entonces estos dependen de
nuestras tres variables de entrada y
cuando tenemos algo así la imagen que
debemos tener en mente es más o menos
algo de este estilo verdad donde cada
punto en tres dimensiones tiene un
vector atado
quizás digamos esto se puede ver algo
complicado pero en esencia pensamos que
a cada punto le asociamos un vector
verdad estamos pensando que el punto es
la entrada y el vector es la salida y en
realidad tendríamos seis dimensiones así
que es por esto que la imagen
es muy enredada entonces la siguiente
pregunta es cómo se calcula el
rotacional de nuestro campo vectorial b
y como ya hemos visto el rotacional lo
que no lo denotamos justamente como root
root de nuestro campo vectorial de y
solo como un recordatorio de cómo
debería verse tendremos digamos un flujo
inducido por el campo vectorial y
podemos imaginar que es aire fluyendo a
través de cada vector verdad y lo que
queremos es una función que en cada
punto diga cuál es la rotación inducida
en cada punto por el flujo y como la
rotación está descrita por un vector
entonces esperamos que esta función que
va a ser el rotacional tenga valores
vectoriales entonces esto deberá ser
algún vector que tenga una salida en
tres dimensiones y por supuesto el
rotacional depende del punto en donde
estemos verdad así que depende de x de
iu y de z este es el valor de entrada
para el rotacional ahora bien una
anotación que es muy útil para calcular
el rotacional es la siguiente
a retomar nuestro triangulito invertido
en habla y vamos a hacer el producto
cruz con nuestro campo vectorial y
quizás si ya conoces lo que es el
producto cruz recordarás que en realidad
esta vez este producto debería ser entre
dos vectores así que qué es lo que
significa esto bueno primero recordemos
que nuestro triangulito invertido es
esencialmente lo podemos pensar como un
vector donde tenemos derivadas parciales
verdad entonces tenemos este vector
donde tenemos la derivada parcial con
respecto de x la derivada parcial con
respecto de ye y la derivada parcial con
respecto
z verdad entonces la idea de este vector
es que en realidad tenemos digamos un
vector con puros operadores
diferenciales como coordenadas verdad y
esto suena sí una bastante digamos
complicado verdad pero quizás muy
elegante pero en esencia lo que nos dice
es que cada vez que tenemos uno de estos
operadores diferenciales cuando le
introducimos una función entonces nos
devuelve la derivada parcial en este
caso por ejemplo con respecto de x
verdad entonces estrictamente hablando
esto no es un vector pero en realidad
nos ayuda para para acordarnos de de
cómo calcular el rotacional verdad es
una es un truco de notación y ahora
hacemos el producto cruz con nuestro
campo vectorial ve el campo vectorial ve
tiene componentes p q y r y por supuesto
no hay que perder de vista que estas
tres componentes dependen de x y y ceta
y sólo como calentamiento veamos cómo
podríamos calcular esto en dos
dimensiones y donde en este caso en dos
dimensiones ya sabemos cuál es la
fórmula verdad entonces vamos a borrar
por ahorita esto de aquí vamos a borrar
esto de aquí y vamos a calcular el
rotacional en dos dimensiones entonces
para el caso de dos dimensiones y
tenemos un campo vectorial con dos
entradas y dos salidas en este caso sólo
vamos a tener nuestro operador
diferencial que tiene parcial respecto
de equis y parcial respecto de iu y
tendremos que hacer el producto cruz con
nuestro campo vectorial en dos
dimensiones que voy a usar las mismas
letras digamos pq en realidad aquí estoy
abusando de la notación verdad en
realidad deberíamos considerar otras
letras porque p y q son justamente las
componentes del caso de arriba pero en
general todos los resultados que
obtenemos con rotación
y este tipo de operadores generalmente
utilizan estas mismas letras solo
estamos haciendo un pequeño abuso de
notación entonces esto es separado del
ejemplo anterior
ahora si nosotros queremos hacer este
producto vamos a llamarle el producto
cruzado y es producto cruzado porque
vamos a hacer este producto de aquí y
luego restamos el producto de los otros
dos verdad entonces lo que tendríamos es
lo siguiente tendríamos la derivada
parcial con respecto de x de esta
componente que sería cubo verdad y luego
restamos el producto de digamos este
producto cruzado que sería la derivada
parcial con respecto de ye de nuestra
componente p y si tú observas lo que
hemos obtenido aquí recordarás que esto
es justamente el rotacional en dos
dimensiones del cual ya hemos hablado
mucho y ya tenemos intuición de qué
significa ahora bien en tres dimensiones
lo que nosotros tenemos que hacer es
tomar un producto cruz verdad nosotros
necesitamos tomar un producto cruz en
tres dimensiones
está relacionado con este tema o quizás
sientes que no lo recuerdas muy bien
deberías buscar los vídeos que existen
ya en khan academy sobre el producto
cruz y es importante que cuentes con
estas bases porque vamos a partir de lo
que es el producto cruz y su
interpretación para poder obtener el
rotacional y ahora bien para obtener
este producto cruz en realidad lo que
tenemos que hacer es calcular un
determinante verdad entonces vamos a
calcular el determinante de un algo que
parece una matriz verdad aquí vamos a
poner tres vectores unitarios el vector
y j y acá y recordemos que el vector y
el vector y no es otra cosa más que el
vector que tiene uno en la primera
entrada y cero en las otras dos el
vector j es el que tiene el uno en la
segunda entrada y el vector que es el
que tiene uno en la tercera entrada y
por supuesto aquí ya te darás cuenta
cuál es digamos
la cosa rara verdad estamos calculando
un determinante y aquí hay vectores
bueno esto solo es un truco de notación
pero vamos a continuar con este producto
cruz digamos ahora en lo que siguen en
el siguiente renglón es colocar el
primer vector de este producto entonces
en este caso tendríamos que poner
parcial respecto de x parcial respecto
de iu y parcial respecto de z y en el
tercer renglón lo que tendríamos que
hacer es poner justamente las
coordenadas del segundo vector en este
caso serían pq y r
y r y esto es por supuesto dependen del
punto x y z entonces aquí ya te puedes
dar cuenta que esto es bastante absurdo
verdad cuando hablamos de matrices en
realidad todo debe ser números para que
podamos hacer multiplicaciones y sumas y
demás pero aquí tenemos una fila de
vectores una fila de operadores
diferenciales verdad y al final tenemos
funciones escalares así que esto es
súper complicado o al menos en principio
por en realidad
esto nos sirve para poder calcular el
rotacional verdad a pesar de todo lo
anterior que hemos dicho en realidad es
genial para poder hacer el cálculo y si
si lo realizas eso nos daría la fórmula
del rotacional en tres dimensiones así
que vamos a detenernos aquí y mejor
continuamos en el siguiente vídeo para
no hacer este vídeo más largo nos vemos